this one's gonna be Captain Morgan
there's gonna be Costco I bet let's try
it never hear a little little phrase
called don't judge a book by it's cover
no why would I not judge a book by what
I'm using to buy it
that's the whole premise behind is that
Costco has their own generic brand I've
heard Kirkland is surprisingly good I
feel like all Kirkland products are
pretty tight I think I dated a girl that
wore Kirkland brand jeans give me the
alcohol
let's let's get to smelling well twos
definitely darker Cheers okay you took
your whole one
it tastes like eggnog - big [ __ ] honey
that is not captain Morgan's that's not
Captain Morgan it's Captain Morgan
brings back a lot of bad memories ooh
smells even sweeter it is even sweeter
this packs more of a punch yeah it's
like a gingerbread man yeah like a drunk
gingerbread man
number two Costco and number one Captain
Morgans well that's what I fed I think
that's what Captain Morgan is I would
never drink something that tasted like
that yeah I agree
number two its tattoos Captain Morgan
one is Costco oh damn it I think my
initial thought was that this is Captain
Morgan but I'm gonna change it and say
that this is Costco and it's a copycat
[Music]
yeah so this is the infamous Grey Goose
has the same quality as the Costco break
that went down pretty easy
yeah like Ke$ha I'm yelling timber
that's like drinking Alex Mack if Alex
Mack was a liquid oh this is like
incredibly smooth this one is smoother
than the first one
- is slightly more palatable my lips
burn one has got to be great goose its
way fancier yeah it just feels like I
should be on a rooftop veranda when I
think
and this feels like maybe a lower to the
ground brand to is goose I think one is
Costco one is Greg goose
who is great goose one and finally we
different one is Costco because all the
vodkas I drink at bars which are the
nicer vodkas make me go to is Costco one
of their goose and she's saying the
opposite damn it Costco you failed me
stop wasting your money on this I'm not
the biggest Canaan with you in person
and honestly I really don't like shot
verbs hashtag shoppers no they look
exactly the same
literally the same color the same
everything this is like dehydrated four
weeks in the desert key colors I think
that's the Crown Royal okay Polly I know
what it tastes like it's the taste of my
unhappy childhood
it's like someone with whiskey breath
talking really close to your face yeah
what is that like oh yeah this is way
harsher I only took like half a sec know
number one is the bathroom
I agree number ones taste like Crown
Royal who is Crown Royal and one is
Costco I think the opposite one is Crown
Royal - this is the corral can you agree
on this you see do we win a prize is the
prize more shots
yeah the whiskey was pretty great
like the vodka was just so clean it's
almost dangerous it was unbelievable
by the vodka with caution is that you're
gonna have a party yeah
Costco if you're listening right now I
believed in you I felt like you would be
the superior liquor well in fact where
were you Costco's living a life of
luxury and the latest about alcohol is
stupid everybody's trying to get to the
same finish line we're all trying to get
caught up so whether you get there by
walking or you get there on a scooter or
you get there on a Segway or you get
there on a private jet from the park
we're all getting there